o trabalhador de shamu vasco léo é como
diz ela na apresentação do chef de
cozinha e vim falar um pouco sobre
gastronomia e do conhecimento é
gastronomia um pouco eu procuro me é um
objeto é uma ciência como a história é
cirurgia é química
usando dados determinado povo é consumo
terminar as quantidades e mesmo o time
tem também as suas formas muito próprias
que nós chamamos de fichas técnicas
serão como cozinha mesmo é a mesma coisa
a mesma coisa feita por diversas pessoas
com os mesmos ingredientes que só será
determinada a falar do que não se
aprende
todas estas coisas que eles poderão
aprender na escola e com isto disse que
iria falar do que não se aprende na
escola
minha experiência minha experiência ou
curso alimentar na escola sobretudo de
um show muito antes disso
estou em casa com os meus pais como o
pai quanto de mãe com as refeições
faziam diariamente e também
especialmente ao xii semana quando
fazemos uma sessão cult frente ao
mercado comprar todos os produtos para
fazer aquela moça ou até o lanche
convívio juntamente comigo
família todo todas estas ações antes das
refeições eram já em si um ato de de
conhecimento porque o igor porque é que
um comprar aqui o produto e no outro por
que é que vão fazer determinada coisa
o almoço ou jantar
poderia dizer que o conhecimento que os
meus pais tiveram os quais deus a voz e
com o conhecimento que eu tive perda é é
a minha vitória vitória rural é com
algumas dificuldades
fazia uma linha tipicamente o discurso
dos cursos disponíveis reservas
o site da organização do do corpo porque
o fazia por ter ido um pouco um pouco
não tanto assim mas é mais ou menos isso
fazia xixi de muito mais rural é muito
mais é muito mais pobre
em contraponto com a minha avó conceição
está na foto à direita naquela praia
death metal mas vinha um pouco mais quem
quer demais estados com nível cultural
um pouco diferente
o acesso é livre acesso é
particularmente onde já fazia site é
estrangeiro é particularmente da cozinha
da cozinha francesa e as influências
vieram também do
dodô e mídia é ganhando este gosto pela
cozinha é criado pelos meus pais e pela
e pelas minhas avós cd sem dúvida alguma
posso afirmar que o que o morten hoje
pela turquia vem em grande parte por
este convívio é a volta da mesa ea volta
da cozinha
comecei então a desenhar para o próximo
aos amigos em casa apenas experiências
pouco elaboradas passo a passo e foi
fazendo coisas mais complexas foi o
zenit também é que um fator importante
porque troquei o papel de observador e e
de crítica é coletivamente o que
desejavam e eu experimentava aqui tem um
papel invertido do país e era eu
criticar nem o advogado relativamente ao
que fazia experiências como disse é
importante para o meu crescimento
enquanto cozinha vi então a importância
de fazer de fazer várias vezes até
aperfeiçoar e aprender um pouco com os
dedos o movimento e assim criar
juntamente com o aprendizagem grammy de
base para o conhecimento na minha área
que é de primeira
além da voz e dos meus amigos e toda a
transparência
o senhor é muito importante disse na
apresentação
minha formação é enquanto desenhar
enquanto pessoa
foi precisamente odone que chamei a
história do tony e defendi
então odone
era um senhor de uma prensa invulgar é
um dinheiro que criaram com músicas e as
crianças e os jovens e emagrecer o gante
é um cozinheiro mais um pouco gordo
baixo uma aparência um pouco como kt
este este é o tony foi só a mesma tática
eu gosto de viajar na internet por
diante de uma fotografia de corte por
exemplo ficar em manter uma imagem por
exemplo o bigode é quase igual a quase
total para garantir então otoni em um
estágio que eu fiz num motel ficou nos
seus estágios de pré-época depois como o
benfica teve grande estiveram lá o real
madrid e valência é equipada qual odone
era o chefe de cozinha otoni teria de
fazer as refeições todas do a equipa do
valência o slide show especial mostra os
primeiros sinais
o almoço pois tem muitas paragens e tem
imensas foi um êxito ele estava sozinho
a equipe estava presente no no hotel era
militar e mente eram maioritariamente
engenheiros franceses sabem tem muito
orgulho né
provavelmente por toda a herança e toda
a cultura gastronômica estréia e pelo
papel que hoje ocupam né na economia
mundial
então não olhava otoni com muito bons
olhos o tony estavam com ele a sua sorte
e trip muitas coisas para fazer na
altura odone número azáfama diária
nelas e tudo o resto que morra mão
esquerda e tiveram de ligar de mão
esquerda continua a trabalhar só com mão
direita
o trabalho era o mesmo conta
a cidade no dia seguinte o dólar
encontrou trabalho
nelas os alunos conseguiram queimar a
mão direita e também anthony estava com
as duas mãos milhares e não conseguiu
desviar
é claramente precisava de jura e os
outros não iam lá é eu e uma outra
estagiária que estava presente
vamos ajudar otoni e fomos nós a sua mão
esquerda e seu mundo virar e precisa
mesmo de computar o resto das refeições
da equipa do valência até o final do
estágio
no fundo tudo bem a equipa técnica
inclusive tiveram a cozinha
agradecemos foi um momento importante e
temos bateram palmas to the - o otoni e
infelizmente não gostaria de concluir
que devemos trabalhar com o tony e eu e
outra rapariga conseguimos absorver o
conhecimento e aprender e se calhar mais
no resto do brasil do estágio com os
outros todos os meios franceses de
escola e muito mais técnicos e muito
mais
uma figura um pouco diferente
então vamos construir o caminho enquanto
enquanto cozinheiro foi cimentando de
identidade sabendo cria o que crê o que
for e de forma diferente é dodô já tinha
feito corrigir algumas coisas e não foi
nestas resta esse conjunto de fatores
vão permitir criar alguma coisa
é foi pedido uma vez para fazer um prato
uma vista e que foi acidente eo tempo de
cozinhar de cozinha que eu faço eu não
sei o que é que havia de fazer então
podemos pensar um pouco e saber
envelhecer é algo que eu vivesse em
disse
e por que não as possibilidades de
lisboa é eu moro em lisboa
lisboa lisboa e particularmente o dia de
santo antônio e os reajustes reais
passam se passam pela cidade então foi
foi eu quiser seguir
era aí que eu queria fazer o prato foi
excelente e efetivo da cozinha que eu
faço equipe minhoca treino no real então
queria que tivesse no real no prato que
iria fazer um pouco da vivência e toda a
festividade que é o santo antônio
pra mim tem um significado muito muito
particular não só pelo público que vai
dizer mas também pelo fato dos meus dois
pais fazerem anos no dia de santo
antônio de uma ligação e no final então
então precisamente no dia de santo
antônio ea fechar os aniversários dos
meus pais iam sempre os favoritos
primeiro a ser guiada ao ver um pouco de
alegria é mais tarde um pouco quando era
pequeno brilho acender fogueiras sangria
ver a festa toda é reais que conseguir
depois sozinho e até a noite de santo
antónio é uma branca conhecer bem a
noite sem vitória em lisboa um pouco
confusa
me ter no fim de partilhar estas
invenções que eu sentia um prato colher
mostrar todas as pessoas
como é que eu ia fazer isso é a trilha
de criar aqui uma lista o mapa de
interações experiências que já tinha já
tive diz em ver alguns traços de
identidade teoria transpor do real com a
cimpor real teria então era a cultura e
as tradições trilhão estarão presentes
lembrando lembrando a voz tudo o que me
ensinaram e um pouco de cultura e
ciência polar também teve comigo ia
explodir os portugueses querem estar
presentes no número real é muito pelo
meu pai e por um chefe com quem
trabalhar e corrigir um grande amigo
foi um professor que sem dúvida fez um
trabalho excelente e comprar alguns
produtos e introduziu os nerds temia
portuguesa como o caso de chi chi são
uma espécie de remorso e número de novos
produtos vários tipos de feijão à luz e
já não se utilizavam os que eu comprar e
acho que é um trabalho importante e
temos que fazer enquanto a abertura
também outras culturas
será sempre importante não só enquanto
chefe de cozinha enquanto o senhor somos
influenciados por tudo o que vivemos e
pelas culturas por viagens por pessoas
que conhecemos e cidade o à vontade de
conhecer sempre mais também continuar a
estar atualizado com técnicas novas do
euro livros falar começou hoje um
exemplo muito grande desta desta vontade
de conhecer sempre mais foi precisamente
por formarem um senhor com contentei
i o tempo de 42 anos com mari arzak tem
um restaurante em san sebastián
vai pra casa um salto importante no
trabalho e conhecemos e tornamos amigos
e eu fui estagiar para o o o restaurante
the well onde está um pequeno
laboratório e ainda hoje com as
tentarmos faz questão de ir lá e já tem
uma equipa muito grande trabalhar com
ele mas faz questão de ir lá e estar
sempre atualizado e e praticar coisas
novas
quem então a dilma uma série de
diretrizes para para criar o meu próprio
agora teria lugar nos produtos
acompanhe o real que tenta simplificar
luz em algumas famílias é essa salada
obviamente essa ladra ultimado com os
homólogos pimentos assados em estar
presente e tenho que respeitar aqui
então algumas coisas
a figura dos ingredientes que matava
duro e estar presente no prato alface
estava fresca eu entrava crocante
qualquer está acontecendo é sangria
também estar presente aqui um pouco
fazendo fazendo a alegria só humano de
todos os ingredientes
o melhor é sempre é mais do que só uma
todos os ingredientes é um bom exemplo
disso
como é que conseguimos fazer contra um
grande time uma uma coisa boa e vai
ajudar na festa eo álcool também gaúcho
iremos também achei linhas enquanto
navas no real
a gordura deixar linhas e pinga no pão
que não devia chinês
o goleador pagar as linhas é e o
grelhador que gracher linhas também
pensei um pouco no senhor e grandes
cheias
depois a festa todo o ambiente de festa
também tenham de estar presente então no
real teria copiado as cores do movimento
o chai do meio jurídico algum movimento
é e até a música então o real que eu que
eu criei linhas é tema de diversas
formas
rob sendo alguns critérios anteriormente
a ser linha está lá assada com o inter
vão instalar em forma de almôndega coroa
absorver a gordura do linha está numa
pequena salada marinada a volta do prato
e no olho no fundo do prato é uma
marinada com todos os remédios
penso que tenha o meu real é que não sei
se teria xingado o objetivo foi proposto
eu junto sim mas acima de tudo não era o
objetivo final é que teria sido mais
importante neste exercício é o caminho
para chegar lá eo exercício todo que eu
eo exercício o que eu fiz anteriormente
o que é que me influenciar porque no
fundo é importante para mim
as influências que eu tive importância
da escola e importância do que não se
aprende na escola toda a vivência está
aí no fundo aprender a fazer aprender
com os erros
como já foi dito anteriormente muito
importante ea capacidade de voltar a
fazer para superar esse - eu fiz
é é aprender e ver continuar a evoluir
temos o real
o real está montado continua a dizer só
falta então a música é obrigado a todos
espero que nenhum estado
o erro